that takes us back to the n-word with a
hard R sure why
for the particular examples that I was
given for the particular conversations
that I was having if you're going to
have challenging conversations around
certain words I think you should
probably be able to say them otherwise
it feels really ridiculous to me that's
why you still believe that
um for com yes and not like calling
people those words but having
conversations about those words I would
say that I still believe I am but don't
you think as you said that using those
words
actually gives motivation and strength
to people who have hate in their hearts
I think depending on the context of
what's going on
um I think that that's going to be a big
driver in terms of how people are going
to perceive or take it so in a
conversation about the n-word I don't
think I would normally say the N word we
just talk about the word much the same
way that like in um like say like in a
movie like in Django people use the N
word should that be censored in that
movie or in the context of that movie is
it being employed in a way where these
aren't good people you're not supposed
to like them and that's what the
audience walks away with
yeah but that context is different than
conversation it feels like in
conversation
you using that word normalizes it and
that normalizing that word is going to
make it easier for people who use that
word in a hateful way to use it same
with the f word this the F slur
if you use that
casually and normalize it
in a way that's not hateful you use in a
way that's not hateful but you the side
effect is that it normalizes it then
people who do use it in a hateful way
will be more likely to use it therefore
mathematically looking at the equation
of the number of times the n-word or the
f word is used throughout the world it
increases the number of times it's used
in a hateful way yeah I think that and
you're part of that problem Stephen I
don't I don't agree I understand I
understand the thought process
um but I don't know if using certain
words within different contexts is going
to necessarily normalize like the
hateful use of that word
um that is an argument that I've heard
people use somebody will say like okay
well hold on that should never be used
ever because by virtue of you
normalizing it even in an inoffensive
environment you increase the proclivity
for people to use it in a potentially
more offensive environment and my
argument is always like no I don't think
that crossover exists but if you did
want to take that argument and maybe you
do feel this way I think that you get
really problematic when you run into
communities that do use certain words
that people would say well they should
be allowed to do it so for instance if
you think that any utterance of the
n-word at all is highly problematic it
might increase hatred and like the
entire rap industry has to dramatically
change the way that they engage with the
n-word and obviously a lot of people
that criticize people's use of the
n-word aren't going to turn to rappers
and say well you guys can't say it
either no it's who I mean it's who uses
the n-word that's what it's not so it's
not just the word it's the
the it it is context dependent uh but I
would say that you as a white person
having conversations
the context there is the kind that would
lead to in the increase in hate do you
think the n-word should be expensive in
the dictionary no and I believe there's
a Wikipedia page on it and it's not
censored uh yeah I think it should be in
the dictionary I think the context of
casual conversation
like like I said I just believe that on
the internet
having humor having fun conversations as
you have on your streams
that leads to the normalization of the
word without any educational value
I think I would I think I would agree
with that no sorry so there's a
difference between F slur and n-word and
both I think should not be used in a fun
way but the f word was used in the fun
way for a longest time for sure uh and I
I'll I'll tell you something that
bothers me about your streams not your
stream your streams and basically every
other stream is the the Casual use of
the r word oh the ableism yeah I don't
know if it's about the able I don't even
know
listen it's complicated I'm not like
virtue signaling here ableism isn't a
virtue signal I mean like it's a
legitimate yeah like I get emails from
fans that say like hey like I deal with
this particular issue every time you use
this word kind of feels like you're
attacking me like just like so it's not
it's a valid concept yeah it's just
something Cuts wrong for me like for
example I'm not bothered by
I am bothered by the excessive use of
the word [ __ ] okay but not
in the same way the moderate use of the
word [ __ ] what is it I'm curious and
when somebody calls somebody an r word
what is it that what is the feeling that
you get that makes you feel bad about it
it signals to me that you don't
give a damn about
people who are struggling
in ways that you are not struggling like
that that signals to me like um about
the experience of others
do you think that there are other other
words also that could convey like a
similar feeling to your what because it
feels like you've drawn a pretty special
circle around because like I imagine oh
this guy's you're an uneducated dumb
[ __ ] you're a networker like
the whole point with the culture so I'm
trying to feel my feeling is a kind of
you know I'm a human being that exists
in a social context that we're all
evolving that language together it just
feels wrong like you know the word [ __ ]
for example it really bought like a
friend on your streams and in general
calling a woman a stupid [ __ ] really
bothers me but it's not just the word
[ __ ] it's context like for example me
personally I'm speaking to me personally
like badass [ __ ]
is is different than stupid [ __ ] way
bad [ __ ] or something is different than
yeah of course way different sure I
think it speaks to a bigger sense of
Civility and respect for human beings
that are not like you
that's what that's that's the feeling
that I'm bothering so I guess what I'm
trying to say here is um
just because people speak in this kind
of way
in the gaming world and streams doesn't
mean that you like a lot of people look
up to you it doesn't mean young people
especially doesn't mean that you don't
have the responsibility to sort of stand
alone from the crowd because you're
somebody that values the power of
affected this course
and
to be effective discourse there's some
level of Civility so you can be the sort
of the beacon of Civility in that world
versus giving in to the uh the
derogatory words because like you have
to
you have to lift people out of that
world out of the muck of
um what I would say is like drama and
ineffective discourses like I think
that's one of your missions right is
like to inspire the world through
conversation through debate through
effective discourse yeah so I guess I'm
just calling you out that I I think
using our word for me personally as a
fan that that believes in your mission
it just makes you look
ineffective and bad and uninspiring to
young people that look up to you because
those young people are going to use
those words that you're using and
they'll do it much less effectively sure
this the problem yeah I guess the
challenge is always just like finding
the line like yeah my my vocabulary
shifted dramatically from even even from
like two or three years ago I think my
vocabulary shifted quite a bit as we've
like we've kind of gotten rid of some
words and some things are kind of coming
out
um the r word is one that has kind of
gone out and come back and gone out and
come back that one we've definitely gone
back and forth on I know there are
different thoughts about it in different
communities on the internet this is
interesting I'm just telling you yeah
for me it cuts
and I'm not a social justice Warrior
type it costs pretty hard
like what you're saying is I'm going to
lose the subscriber if I'm no it's not
no I'm just kidding I know I just I
actually have had to empathize harder
because I'm like maybe this is not a
very good person that's what I feel like
if you're so carelessly using that word
then maybe you're not actually thinking
deeply about
the suffering in the world like to be a
student of human nature you really have
to think about other humans and other
experiences that are unlike your own
yeah of course and so that's the sense I
get but at the same time you're you're
also like the grandpa I mean ages who's
trying to be cool with a young kids a
lot a lot of the reason young kids look
up to you is like you also know the
language of the internet yeah but I mean
it doesn't that's not an excuse to use
words we think shouldn't be used I guess
the question that I that I would have
because it's always a struggle and to
some extent it's kind of happened is
let's say that like three years ago I
would have said I'm no longer saying the
artwork that's just I'm just gonna get
rid of that in my vocabulary like is
there a chance that today we would be
having a conversation about like why do
you call people dumb [ __ ] like is that
really appropriate like does this attack
at the core of like somebody's like
level of intelligence education
opportunities in life like is that where
they you know you don't think so I think
that's a as the kids say cope do you
really think so I think because because
the words have been moved in a way where
it's like this was okay now it's not
this is know so you're standing your
ground by using listen you could you you
could you could
but I think it's better to use those
words if you want to defend the ground
word stand on to use them rarely and
deliberately versus how you currently
use them which is to express and emotion
like you I'm going to be honest you use
our word not when you're at your best
true and so that's not that's generally
that could be true for a lot of swearing
too though but yeah I know what you mean
no but like you know that our word is
offensive you know and there's a part of
it is like the the you tell yourself
that like you're still kind of fighting
political correctness by using it a
little bit when you say it no I don't
think so I think I'm trying to think in
terms of like where is The Virtue where
like there's a whole bunch of arguments
for why some words are okay some words
aren't okay or whatever and I try to
like think more along those lines rather
than but um like there's gonna be like a
lot of phrases where like if the r word
has come out the conversation is over
like I know that like things my brain is
shut down the person I'm talking to but
there's like there's a lot of words also
in terms of like it like if you ever
hear me say like [ __ ] [ __ ] in a
debate it's like it's done like this
conversation is over there's no way that
anything productive is happening past
that point I think [ __ ] [ __ ] is not
I think it's ineffective it's not civil
but it's not
it doesn't bother me in the way
is is basically when you speak in a way
that I know there's a group that's going
to be heard by that
not only do I think about the hurt that
group experiences I think of you as a
lesser intellectual like as a lesser
person who's thinking about the world
what bothers me the most is just what
kind of
um mindset that inspires young in young
people or especially when you're in a
public figure and a lot of people look
up to you so I definitely don't think
sort of this idea
the r word is not the battleground of
expanding the Overton window of
discourse
okay like I I don't think it'll lead to
dumb [ __ ]
being canceled uh two years later unless
that word is hurting people's experience
which I don't foresee that happening I
think legitimately
our word and F slur and calling women
[ __ ]
it's context matters here too like of
course but just the way I've heard you
use it it is not is from emotion and
it's from frustration and It ultimately
is rooted in disrespect I don't I think
it's ineffective and of course like who
gets to say I don't know but I'm saying
somebody who would my like I admire
effective conversations and I admire
great humor dark humor wit
to me oftentimes the use of the r word
in the way you've used them the way I
see the community use it is none of
those things it contributes not at all
to the humor and so on now I could see
it might contribute to the to the
camaraderie of that particular group
especially when they normalize the use
of that word
you kind of take some of the edge off
but you forget that there's a
and large number of other people that
don't have the chemistry the don't hear
the music of the friendship that you
have the relationship you have instead
they hear the normalization of a hateful
word and It ultimately has an impact
that's hateful and then people like me
who show up you know I haven't watched
much of your stuff it turns me off from
like uh a couple of times your content
came came before me like and I listened
to it a little bit turned me off
completely I didn't understand
how good your heart is I didn't
understand how your mission of actually
uh direct do you radicalized people help
people like you're uh and increase the
level of good faith discourse in the
world I didn't understand any of that
because like what I was hearing is
pretty rough like the r award type of
stuff and I just feel like the benefit
cost analysis is heavy on the cost
gotcha that's so I just have to sort of
call this out okay I think it and I
straight up think it's wrong
but that's my own that's why you think
it's wrong
because it's hurting people without any
benefit to you whatsoever when you say
hurting people do you mean the person
I'm using it at or do you think there's
like those
group the third third group it's good
feedback right I always consider
everything especially I respect you like
you're a really smart guy
um something that I always kind of like
fight over in terms of like language or
like who to attack or what to attack or
what to do is that um it's very hard to
draw like what boxes
um are okay to install people on versus
one aren't so for instance if I call
somebody like a Nazi with a lot of
vitriol I'm okay with every single Nazi
being negatively affected by that
because
that category intrinsically calls upon
at some level of more condemnation for
me right whereas like if I'm out there I
try not to do like image related jokes
right I don't want to call you like oh
you're a fat [ __ ] loser because
there's a lot of people that are fat
that are overweight where I don't want
them to feel bad I don't want them I'm
not trying to call you out or like
insult you so there's like a lot of um
you say cost benefit I like like a lot
of collateral damage from a world like
that where there's no purpose in doing
that
um so certain words are easy to get rid
of they're off the table right epsler
and we're like like these are not words
you call people because you're there's
so much collateral it's not worth it
we've got some words where it's like if
you have some form of like mental thing
it is a bad thing you're not a bad
person person but just using that word
could feel like a collateral damage to
those people and then there's other
categories of words so like if I say
that like um this person is like they're
it's a stupid [ __ ] Republican right
there's probably some Republicans that
aren't dumb that I don't want to feel
called out by that like are those types
of phrases that you think should be
completely removed as well or I'm kind
of curious so this completely removed
just so we're clear yeah I'm not
referring to censorship oh no I'm not
even talking about I'm just just a
person like emotionally like removed is
the wrong word though like I care about
like I'm not trying to listen to people
on the internet saying like you
shouldn't say that word that's not good
I mean
I'm trying to look to your mind and
heart and you think we're talking today
is you're betraying your gift you're
better than this you think it's
indicative of like a more flippant
thought process where it's like the only
way you can say that word is if you're
ignoring the hurt and suffering of those
people and if you're somebody that says
even those people you're ignoring the
the state of language because I think
you're getting to the point because it's
not about a single word it's about like
uh it's music and I just feel like there
is uh
it's a strong note that ruins the melody
gotcha and I don't think I can say you
know you shouldn't use the r word or
whatever I'm just speaking to I'm just
listening to music and reviewing the the
final result it's not necessarily
because maybe one use of the word the r
word
uh strategically or part of an actual
like or when you've built up a
camaraderie that's sandwiched in in like
some love but then you try to reveal
there like because you're talking about
a lot of there's a bunch of drama you
have a but you have friends with whom
you're worrying and stuff and they're
all a little bit beautifully insane and
you've said that you are becoming more
and more insane it's beautiful to watch
it's The Human Condition late before us
wonderful and some of that is swearing
and so on so it's a tricky thing but
um the whole skill of
discourse just like it is with dark
humor is walking that line I just feel
like it's uh
overuse of the r word and I don't want
to die in that ground because I don't
think it's that that represents like
there's certain things like that
it feels like it ruins the music I don't
you know it's just saying like a dumb
Republican or dumb Democrat I don't yeah
that ruins it too a little bit depends
on how you use it uh you can be lazy
with that yeah you know like even
overuse of the word I think Bots is
what's used for people who don't think
or something I don't actually know the
definition I'm offended on the on behalf
of robots
and that might be a compliment soon
okay exactly what I guess bot means you
don't think yeah you're like an NPC
you're just kind of interesting again
I'm a fan on behalf of NPCs I I count
myself as one but there's a sense if you
say Bots too much
that you're just dismissing people like
everything I say is right and anyone
that disagrees with me is a bot that
that's lazy too sometimes it's funny
sometimes it's effective uh basically
saying a lot of people in the mainstream
Media or something like that or Bots
okay that's a little bit of that is
effective but too much it becomes
ineffective and I'm trying to speak to
that yeah and I'm just the reason we're
highlighting clear examples
like the n-word
Joe Rogan had to contend with that all
right yeah
I think it's ineffective it makes you
less effective at this course I but like
like you've talked about many times
language is a tricky one
it's always hard because you talk about
like constructing a Melody there's not
one Melody that sounds good to everyone
but there are probably certain notes
that like if you got rid of them
everybody's still going to like it about
as much and you don't really lose
anything there's a whole other part of
an audience that might be more willing
to listen yeah of course and it's not
about losing the magic of that Melody
like you don't want to be vanilla
I just feel like there's stuff that
doesn't need to be there yeah for sure
it's fat but then again you're the other
thing that people should understand
that might be listening to this you're
streaming many hours a day for many
years I don't know it's 11 or 12 I think
yeah I started in 2010. and so one of
the things that people can do is just
clip out anything you're going through
the full Human Experience of emotion
anger fear frustration all of it so of
course there's going to be moments when
you're not the best version of yourself
anything else to say about the language
it's complicated I'm still always trying
to figure it out you know there are
opinions that I have that have changed
throughout the years it's possible that
the r word has always been the next one
on the chopping block that we're all
kind of looking at but people always
worried about that treadmill but it's
possible in a year or two I'll have a
different view on it or I'll have
changed away some of the words I use and
that um yeah it's definitely like a it's
always like a work in progress there's
always like different communities that
feel different ways about different
words yeah
yeah but you acknowledge that there's
people out there that are never going to
talk to you
they're never gonna think of you as a
good man because you use the on N word
with the hard R publicly in the past I
mean yeah those people exist but I mean
there are some people that are beyond my
reach which I'm okay with like there's
gonna be some people because of things
that have been involved or even ideas
that I have now that might make them
beyond my reach
um something you said earlier is very
true I think the goal is to like
identify what are the elements that you
can cut out that aren't integral to your
message but it could be alienating to
more people and those are probably the
things that you identify but I think
that you can get lost in yourself or
lost on the Internet or lost in a you
know at the outside of yourself if
you're trying to appeal to every single
person it's just never going to be the
case and for I actually I like that I've
had the journey that I've had on the
internet that you can find me saying and
defending a lot of insane stuff 10 years
ago because I think it shows like a
level of progress and I think I do get a
lot of respect and buy them to certain
communities where it's like I'm not just
some random dude telling you that like
oh you should shouldn't say you know the
f word or the N word like I'm a guy
that's been there that's done it that's
defended it and you can see my whole
past my whole history is laid bare for
you to watch every of you know thousands
of hours of it um but I can show that
like there's growth and evolution and
change that can happen in a person so
yeah and you're honest about that growth
It's Tricky thing because people just
call bring up stuff from your past for
sure I hope we figure out as a
civilization a mechanism
to Clearly say this was this was me two
years ago this was me five years ago
this I'm a different person and like
um because Twitter doesn't care about
that these social mechanisms that bring
stuff up doesn't care about that it's
like one stupid thing you say
it becomes like a Scarlet Letter and I
don't know how to fight that It's tricky
to fight that have you ever seen Men In
Black yes when k j are on the bench and
he says uh person is smart but people
are stupid dumb finicky animals or
whatever there's something that changes
for human dynamics when there is a group
of people that make it so hard to
control like I think one-on-one anybody
can sit across on somebody and admit to
some horrible stuff I used to be uh you
know I abused my husband when I was you
know 20 and I'm 35 and I see it's wrong
or I did this I was addicted to whatever
and you know I made these mistakes
one-on-one it's always easy but in um in
group environments that in group out
group tribalistic thing of like
identifying one thing and then coming to
destroy a person's life is like it's
such a huge like impulse we have and I
think probably when we were like
hunter-gatherers in the force probably
good because you really want to push
weird people out or anything like that
but now on the internet when we can hunt
for any dissenting opinion and just with
ruthless Precision destroy somebody's
life over it it's pretty scary dynamic I
think one of the mechanisms that could
fix it is make it super easy for each
individual person to analyze all the
stupid [ __ ] they themselves have said in
the past like a full recording
because I think people are just honestly
paint a very Rosy picture to their own
brain of of who they have been in the
past yeah of course if we can have
empathy for the fact that we've said
stupid [ __ ] or we're drunk the the
ridiculous things you say the offensive
things you might have said the offensive
things you might have done I just feel
like that would give us the ammunition
to have empathy for others that are like
okay yeah this guy five years ago said
this maybe that doesn't represent them
who doesn't represent who they are any
more than stuff I said five years ago
represents who I am today yeah I feel
like technology can actually enable that
maybe although you're talking about more
more recording and more stuff which
people are already wary of but um it's a
double-edged sword I think there's there
is going to be more and more recording
we have to figure out how to do that in
a way that respects people privacy and
gives them ownership of their data and
so on I've looked at the search history
I've done on Google which for most
people is available like your Google
search history and it's fascinating to
watch the evolution of a human being
like it doesn't seem like the same
person it's like a different person for
sure it's weird it's also hard too with
the internet today I'm gonna be ageist
again but like now all of the people are
thrown together you know whereas like
like I don't want a 27 year old judging
they're usually like a 15 or 16 year
year old like obviously he's in high
school like there is that story that
came out of the um there was a kid that
saved the recording of I think it was
like some white girl I think that she
like got her driver's license and she's
like I can drive now and words with the
a or whatever it's dumb she shouldn't
have said it but I think she was like 15
or 16 when she Tick Tock this or
whatever and he held all of that
recording until she applied and got
accepted to college three years later
and then he released it to get her
kicked out of college and I'm like damn
everything that I had ever said it was
like a 15 16 year old was like
immortalized on the internet my my life
wouldn't have even begun
um and those are insanely high standards
to hold people to
um not that like obviously you shouldn't
be saying those uh you shouldn't be
saying certain words or whatever but you
have to be able to make mistakes in
adolescence like everybody does we all
did everybody did it growing up you know